c'est pas un mirage
c'est incroyable
soldat songé que du haut de ses
pyramides 45 vous content et puis
figurez-vous on est champion du monde de
chenilles le record du monde de la plus
longue chenille a été battue
hier
et mettez vos pieds
on sort en chenille allez c'est parti
[Rires]
et si les Normands étaient aussi
nombreuses c'est parce qu'il y avait
aussi un autre enjeu
les Bretons détenaient en effet le
dernier record homologué avec 1338
chenilles East réunit l'année dernière à
Saint-Brieuc c'était sans compter sur
l'éternel rivalité avec leurs voisins on
a vu ce record des Bretons à
Saint-Brieuc il y a un an et on s'est
dit voilà on va pas leur laisser ça
parce qu'on est normand on va leur
prendre leur record comme on l'aura pris
le Mont-Saint-Michel alors non ça se
passe pas n'importe comment la chenille
c'est main à la taille alors évidemment
en demandant aux partenaires de devant
si vous pouvez bien vous accrocher parce
que si c'est marrant aux épaules c'est
là que le le et là c'est pas c'est pas
tout à fait pareil on n'est pas sûr
d'avoir l'homologation
vendredi je reçois l'agenda presse je
l'ouvre qu'est-ce que je vois lundi 18h
la grande chenille de l'Armada dans
l'agenda presse
de Rouen va venir faire la chenille il a
préféré la plus grande chenille du monde
à la convention de Bernard Cazeneuve il
avait mieux à faire et on en a eu la
confirmation ce matin sur Public Sénat
si je vous dis 394
c'est notre chiffre de jour plus d'un
Français sur 5 c'est la part d'adultes
qui dépasse les plafonds recommandés de
consommation d'alcool depuis 2017 les
autorités sanitaires fixent ces plafonds
à divers par semaine soit de vers par
jour avec des jours de la semaine sans
aucune consommation et quand je dis que
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol préfère la
chenille à l'avenir de la gauche je ne
déconne pas puisque l'année dernière on
a mené notre petite enquête il s'était
filmé les images qui vont suivre sont
véridiques en train de reprendre la
chenille à la guitare électrique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur Boyard monsieur Boyard je vous
demande de vous taire
monsieur brouillard monsieur Boyard je
vous rappelle alors
monsieur Boyard
je prononce à votre rencontre un rappel
à lampe avec inscription au
procès-verbal Emmanuel Macron a battu le
record du monde de partage très loin
c'est sans montage
les avons
[Musique]
pas une photo c'est une vidéo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nouvelle épisode judiciaire pour Nicolas
Sarkozy qui a été entendu en audition
libre dans un sous-dossier de l'affaire
du financement des biens de sa campagne
présidentielle de 2012 le domicile de
l'ancien chef de l'État ensuite été
perquisitionné l'intermédiaire
sulfureuse y attaquée d'une principale
témoin à charge contre Nicolas Sarkozy
avait opéré on s'en souvient une
spectaculaire volte-face sont le
dédouanant la justice cherche à savoir
si l'ex-président a joué un rôle dans
cette rétractation
je précise que je n'ai jamais galocher
un cousin mais le panel a pu le penser
on fait rien
c'est terrifiant les mecs les papas
poussaient c'est une horreur
pendant que les enfants s'élèvent des
vrais mecs viril quoi
alors on dit toujours que derrière un
grand homme il y a toujours une femme et
bien la voilà je confirme et là c'est
vrai que d'ailleurs les grandes femmes
aucun personne n'a rien
[Applaudissements]
fait la vérité
Christine Bravo
[Musique]
et que vous faites la leçon de partout
donc arrête de me donner
à cause de vous personne ne te contraint
à rien tu continues de vivre ta vie et
ben personne ne te contraintes
mais c'est toi qui crie
tu es pas agressif c'est pas agressé on
t'empêchait de vivre on t'empêche pas de
vivre
tu dis n'importe quoi
[Applaudissements]
non mais vous êtes pas passé
votre père vous avez dit à l'époque des
inconnus que vous avez le regard
tellement vide qu'on voit la carte
derrière la tapisserie c'était bien
résumé
ils disaient ça de de ouais c'est vrai
et Bernard en particulier joue très très
bien le videa
on s'inspire de certaines personnes
[Musique]
remporter
Koh-Lanta le feu sacré
[Musique]